und jetzt das heute journal
mit kai soll richter und marietta slomka
guten abend wenn der landesgruppenchef
der csu von einem ökologischen
wirtschaftswunder schwärmt worin die
fraktionschefin der afg aber nur die
demontage der autoindustrie sehen kann
dann ist generaldebatte im bundestag
traditionell gelegenheit für die
opposition zur generalabrechnung mit der
regierung
die ihrerseits aber themen setzen kann
und die bundesregierung setzte heute auf
klimaschutz weniger schaut sich das im
bundestag angehört wer nur horst
seehofers körpersprache nachdenklich in
sich gekehrt ist wenn das ganze kabinett
vorgibt besseres zu tun zu haben als der
ersten rede der generaldebatte zu
lauschen und teile der opposition ist
der regierungsbank gleich tut wenn also
alle ignorieren was vor sich geht dann
spricht alles weil in ihren 13 minuten
redezeit lässt sie deutschland
konsequent untergehen bankencrash
gewalttätige flüchtlinge vermurkste
klimapolitik der bundesregierung
vorgehen
der klimaschutz ist nichts anderes als
ein monströses deindustrialisierung
programm verbunden mit veritabler
arbeitsplatzvernichtung sie verschwänden
aber milliarden um imaginierte
weltuntergänge in ferner zukunft
abzuwenden
viele werden später in der debatte sagen
sie seien das land da draußen anders
positiver angela merkel hat sich eher
vorgenommen dem land zu sagen was jetzt
an offensichtlichen hausaufgaben an
steht nächste woche will das so genannte
klima kabinett beschließen
und weil dann fehlen der großen
koalition zu klären ist spricht merkel
über klimawandel muss er grundsätzlich
wenn wir den klimaschutz vorantreiben
wird es geld kosten
dieses geld ist gut eigentlich wenn wir
ihn ignorieren wird es uns nach meiner
überzeugung mehr geld kosten als wenn
wir etwas tun das ist die wahrheit nicht
so ist nicht die alternative jürgen
trittin ruft merkel zwischendurch
spöttisch zu sie habe für die klimaziele
ja genügend zeit gehabt was merkel so
lächelt zurückweist und was andere
wiederum wir sind nicht durchgehen
lassen wollen
aus dem haushalt fehlt es nicht
erkenntnis ist nicht bekenntnis ist auch
frau merkel nicht in ordnung sondern es
ist endlich ergebnis es ist endlich
handeln das ist was fehlt hören sie auch
immer nur zu reden tun sie endlich was
sowie die begebung das bisher angedeutet
hat würden ja vor allen dingen beim
klimaschutz wieder mal die unteren und
mittleren einkommen belastet werden fakt
ist doch dass die reichsten zehn prozent
in deutschland fast 50 prozent des co2
ausstoßes zu verantworten haben der
spd-fraktionschef war vor einigen wochen
mit heftiger kritik an der union
aufgefallen
heute ist er artig koalitionstreu und
beim klimaschutz wirkt eher einer
demokratietheoretisch für das große
ganze mitnahme beteiligung legitimation
das ist unser verständnis von demokratie
meine damen und herren dass die afg sich
nicht an einen klimakompromiss
beteiligen und sich hier auch keiner
fragen wird bist schon lange klar
der rest der opposition zeigt sich heute
deutlich offener werden die große
koalition der nächste woche überhaupt
ergebnisse
die proteste in hongkong haben längst
auch die deutsche außenpolitik erreicht
als bundeskanzlerin merkel bei ihrem
china-besuch letzte woche das thema
ansprach nahm das chinesische regime das
noch so gerade hin
aber jetzt wurden die glacéhandschuhen
abgestreift peking hat den deutschen
botschafter einbestellt was in der
sprache der diplomatie ja so viel heißt
wie wir sind stinksauer
anlass für die verärgerung ist ein
treffen zwischen außenminister heiko
maas und dem hongkonger aktivisten
joshua wann in berlin
das einmal mehr zeigt wie schwierig
außenpolitik ist wenn man einerseits für
demokratie und menschenrechte einstehen
will ist zugleich oder mit schmerzfreien
kalibern wie china zu tun hat dass heute
anders als früher auch eine
wirtschaftsgroßmacht ist andreas kühner
ist berichtet die proteste in hongkong
sind vandalismus will der chinesische
botschafter den deutschen sagen die
proteste in hongkong sind ein kampf um
demokratie
bild bosch waggon den deutschen sagen
die deutschen sind heute sehr wichtig
der vertreter pekings in deutschland hat
noch nie eine pressekonferenz gegeben
der vertreter der proteste hongkongs ist
medienliebling und medienprofi ihr kampf
der kampf um die wahrheit wird heute in
berlin geführt
dazu gehört dass die botschaft der
volksrepublik zwar manche deutschen
medien reinlässt aber manche auch nicht
für die bild -zeitung die georges waggon
eingeladen hat seit leider kein platz
sagt botschafter kennen und die
deutschen journalisten wundern sich weil
überall plätze frei sind
sie haben vielleicht einige lehrer
presse gesehen ja aber diese lehren
plätzchen sind viel die leute die
dahinter stehen zur zeit da hinten
stehen ein paar kameraleute sonst
niemand dann zeigt china seine version
der hong kong proteste die demonstranten
werden als radikale bezeichnet als
schwerkriminelle verbrecher gewalttäter
und krawallmacher joshua den peking den
anstiftern and schildert ziemlich exakt
das gegenteil wir haben es mit einem
steigenden grad ein barbarischer gewalt
von seiten der polizei zu tun die die
menschenrechte mit füßen tritt
dass außenminister maß beide seiten zur
gewaltlosigkeit aufrief hat ihm scharfe
kritik aus deutschland eingebracht dass
er am montag zu astragon traf eine tiefe
krise mit china vor dem auswärtigen amt
wenn plötzlich chinesische fahnen haltet
euch aus chinas angelegenheiten raus in
peking wird der deutsche botschafter
einbestellt fast alle parteien haben
josh waggon empfangen vor allem eine die
fdp hält merkels china politik für zu
leise und deshalb bedauere ich dass sie
bisher die chance versäumt haben den aus
hongkong zu uns gekommen oppositionellen
joshua von zu empfangen und mit dem
gesperrten merkel wiederholt zwar ihren
appell an chinas regierung den namen
bonn hat sie nicht aber falls die
bundesregierung peking beruhigen will
es ist zu spät bedauerlicherweise haben
mancher deutscher politiker solch eine
als stifter der gewalttat empfangen die
souveränität und sicherheit chinas
gehört respektiert als morgen am abend
zu einem vortrag in die humboldt-uni
kommt fällt er erst gar nicht auf er ist
ja selbst ein student aber er zwingt nun
auch deutschland sich zu entscheiden
nicht nur das verhältnis zu china
russland und sogar zu den usa ist
derzeit schwierig auch zur türkei mit
präsident erdogan bewegt sich die
deutsche beziehungsweise die europäische
außenpolitik in schwerem fahrwasser
wo beim wasser hier durchaus ein
passendes stichwort ist das flüchtlings
abkommen mit der türkei besteht zwar
nach wie vor
trotzdem setzen täglich hunderte
migranten von der türkei nach
griechenland über mit deutlich
steigenden zahlen
bevor wir dazu einen bericht von der
insel lesbos zeigen jetzt erst noch kurz
ein paar daten und fakten im überblick
seit ausbruch des krieges in syrien 2011
leben mehr als 3,6 millionen flüchtlinge
in der türkei
viele wollen weiter nach europa um das
zu verhindern schluss die eu 2016 mit
der türkei einen pakt die türkei
verhindert illegale migration richtung
griechenland und nimmt auch geflüchtete
zurück dafür erhält sie sechs milliarden
euro 5,6 milliarden davon wurden laut eu
bereits bezahlt derzeit verschärft sich
das problem in der ägäis wieder in den
flüchtlingslagern auf den griechischen
inseln sind inzwischen etwa 24.000
geflüchtete registriert die lager völlig
überfüllt und laut dem
flüchtlingshilfswerk der un kamen allein
im august mehr als 8000 menschen aus der
türkei nach griechenland fast dreimal
mehr als im august 2008 zehnter ob die
türkischen trends kontrolleure das nicht
verhindern können oder wollen sei
dahingestellt offiziell hält sich die
türkei an das abkommen
doch präsident erdogan hat ja auch damit
gedroht die grenzen zur eu für syrische
flüchtlinge zu öffnen
die betroffenen griechischen inseln in
der ägäis stellt der neue anstieg der
ankommenden flüchtlingsboote jedenfalls
vor erhebliche probleme
die lager sind überfüllt die behörden
com mit der registrierung nicht
hinterher
annette hilsenbeck berichtet
es war ein verzweifelter akt der neuen
griechischen regierung letzte woche
siedelte sie rund 1400 menschen um
machte sie aus dem lager moria auf der
insel lesbos zum festland vor allem
familien und unbegleitete minderjährige
trotzdem die lage im camp hat sich kaum
entspannt diesmal erreichte lesbos mit
seiner familie vor wenigen tagen in
moria haben sie bisher zwei decken
gekriegt nicht viel mehr
sie hausen außerhalb des eigentlichen
camps in einem zeltlager es ist beengt
wir leben hier mit vier familien in
diesem wort insgesamt sind wir 16
personen
wir haben gefahren auf uns genommen
wussten dass wir ertrinken können das
haben wir getan damit unsere kinder eine
bessere zukunft haben
etwa 10.000 menschen sind es auch jetzt
noch in moria dreimal so viel wie
ursprünglich hier untergebracht werden
sollten
viele sind kinder und unbegleitete
jugendliche und ein drittel der bewohner
ist unter 17 jahre alt täglich kommen
neue menschen ansuchen platz zwischen
denen die schon warten ob sie asyl
bekommen oder nicht bisher monate oder
gar jahrelang dieses system kann so
viele menschen nicht aushalten
generell muss das asylverfahren
beschleunigt werden damit der für mehr
menschen schneller und faire
abgeschlossen werden kann
griechenland will jetzt neue
sachbearbeiter einstellen das
asylverfahren verkürzen und sieht vor
allem den nachbarn in der pflicht den
türkei vertrag zu erfüllen wir fordern
von der türkei dass sie ernsthaft dafür
sorgt dass schlepper netzwerke
zerschlagen werden und dass sie nicht
zulässt dass erneut diese etablierten
flüchtlings routen entstehen das ist
einfacher geworden ist aus der türkei zu
fliegen berichtet ahmed er sei zuvor
sieben mal verhaftet worden sagt er
jetzt beim achten mal hatte
keine probleme gegeben dieses mal haben
die türkischen polizisten so geschaut
wir haben uns einfach gehen lassen
die türkei ist nach wie viele migranten
sich auf den weg über das meer nach
lesbos machen hängt auch von der
türkischen regierung ab sagen blicken
wir auf die türkische perspektive jörg
brase in istanbul
präsident erdogan hatte jüngst gedroht
die grenzen zu öffnen sollte die türkei
nicht mehr finanzielle unterstützung
bekommen ist denkbar dass er das
flüchtlings abkommen ganz aufkündigt
also ich glaube nicht dass er es ganz
aufkündigen will aber sieht so aus dass
man zumindest nach verhandeln möchte die
türkei profitiert ja auch von diesem
abkommen haben es gehört sechs
milliarden euro will die eu zahlen
ankara kritisiert nun dass dieses geld
nicht vollständig überwiesen wurde
bislang und man möchte wohl auch dass
die eu selbst mehr flüchtlinge aufnimmt
denn der druck auf die türkische grenze
von syrischer seite ist in den
vergangenen wochen enorm gestiegen
zehntausende sind vor den kämpfen in
idlib richtung türkei geflohen und
präsident erdogan hat gesagt mehr als
diese 3,6 millionen syrer die sich
zurzeit im land befinden könne das land
nicht verkraften
man sei schließlich nicht das
aufnahmelager europas bisher steht
erdogan denn da selbst unter druck
innenpolitisch steht der unter enormen
druck denn die stimmung in der
bevölkerung hat sich in den vergangenen
monaten noch drastisch gewandelt eine
mehrheit sieht nun in den syrern hier im
lande eine bedrohung eine konkurrenz um
jobs und auch um wohnungen die es hat
auch schon erste angriffe gegeben auf
syrische geschäfte und diese stimmung
macht die regierungspartei akp
mitverantwortlich auch für die wahlen
jeder lage bei der oberbürgermeisterwahl
hier in istanbul man will also jetzt
härte zeigen auch gegen die syrischen
flüchtlinge soll erste abschiebung
gegeben haben oder freiwillige rückkehr
aufgrund von massivem druck die türkei
hat mittlerweile in der tat ein eigenes
flüchtlingsproblem eine eigene
flüchtlingskrise steht unter großem
druck und den gibt es jetzt auch an die
europäer weiter dankeschön rest ambuja
blase und jetzt erstmal die nachrichten
von kaiser bericht
ein schottisches berufungsgericht hat
die zwangspause für das britische
parlament für illegal erklärt damit gab
es mehr als 70 abgeordneten recht die
gegen die sitzungspause bis zum 14
oktober geklagt hatten
allerdings will die regierung von
premierminister johnson gegen das urteil
in berufung gehen
ob das parlament tatsächlich vor dem 14
oktober wieder tagen darf ist noch
unklar
es war in der nacht auf dienstag in den
zwangsurlaub gestartet dabei hatte es
tumultartige protestieren
am abend gab die britische regierung
bekannt welche szenarien sie im
schlimmsten fall bei einem brett ohne
vertrag erwartet demnach könnte
innerhalb eines tages die zahl der
lastwagen die über den kanal kommen um
die hälfte sinken die versorgung mit
frischen lebensmitteln und medizin
könnte ebenso gestört werden wie die
grenzüberschreitende strafverfolgung und
finanztransaktionen
außerdem bereite man sich auf heftige
proteste und gegen proteste vor
öffentlichkeit und unternehmen seien
nicht genügend auf einen no deal
drechselt vorbereitet ist im falle eines
wahlsieges werde er das jordantal
annektieren mit dieser wahlkampf
botschaft hat israels regierungschef
netanjahu heftige kritik ausgelöst weil
palästinensern arabischen staaten und
der eu auch deutschland warnte vor einem
verstoß gegen das völkerrecht das
jordantal befindet sich eine grenze zu
jordanien und gehört zum westjordanland
dass die palästinenser für sich
beanspruchen und 60.000 von ihnen leben
dort neben 5000 israelischen siedlern
erst ein gesprächsangebot an die usa
dann ein neuer waffentest nordkorea hat
nach eigenen angaben ein so wörtlich
extra großes mehrfach raketenwerfer
system getestet zwei geschossen seien
rund 330 kilometer weit in richtung meer
geflogen bestätigte das nachbarland
südkorea das nordkoreanische fernsehen
zeigte bilder die machthaber kim bei der
überwachung des raketentests zeigen
sollen wenige stunden zuvor hatte seine
regierung ein neues us angebot im
atomstreit gefordert
heute vor genau 18 jahren steuerten
al-kaida-terroristen zwei flugzeuge in
das world trade center ein weiteres in
das pentagon ein viertes stürzte auf ein
feld
viele amerikaner gedachten heute der
fast 3000 opfer so lasen angehörige die
namen derer vor die in den new yorker
zwillingstürme starben bei der
gedenkfeier am pentagon drohte
us-präsident trump potenziellen
künftigen angreifern mit verheerender
geld in katalonien ist der elfte
september regional feiertag und den
nutzen hunderttausende traditionell um
in barcelona für die unabhängigkeit von
spanien zu demonstrieren
dieses mal kamen rund 600.000 deutlich
weniger als in den vergangenen jahren
2014 auf dem höhepunkt der
unabhängigkeits proteste waren es
dreimal so viele
vor zwei jahren hatte das katalanische
parlament die unabhängigkeit ausgerufen
12 verantwortlichen drohen deshalb lange
gefängnisstrafen das auf dem
fußballplatz nicht mit wasserbällen
geworfen wird ist klar
und das fankurven keine worte der reinen
höflichkeit sind auch aber die zeiten in
denen selbst widerlich rassistische oder
homophobe beleidigungen als irgendwie
akzeptabel galten die sind vorbei
die fifa hatte im sommer angekündigt da
auch gegenüber zuschauern künftig härter
vorzugehen bis hin zum spielabbruch
die französische liga hat den neuen fifa
kodex übernommen und tatsächlich setzen
schiedsrichter das inzwischen auch durch
was prompt diskussionen ausgelöst hat
thomas walde berichtet
der pfiff halte im ganzen land nach in
der 27 minute unterbrach der
schiedsrichter die partie in nizza gegen
marseille nach dem netz us-fans
homophobie lieder sangen und banderolen
zeigten auf denen von [ __ ] die
rede war
die fifa hatte schiedsrichter dazu
aufgefordert ich denke der
schiedsrichter hat zu recht unterbrochen
so war es im stadion ist nicht
akzeptabel das muss allen klar sein
siebenmal unterbrachen schiedsrichter
partien der ersten und zweiten liga
seither haben frankreich und der fußball
eine kontroverse debatte
homophobie hat keinen platz im fußball
und auch nicht in den stadien
ich will nicht dass spiele deswegen
unterbrochen werden ich bin auch gegen
homophobie aber ich will nicht als
geisel genommen werden
ich habe angewiesen dass spiele nur noch
unterbrochen werden wenn es auf den
tribünen eine gefahr gibt damit berief
der fußball präsident einen anderen
präsidenten aufs spielfeld
der fußball soll menschen
zusammenbringen nicht spalten und dazu
muss er die werte der eintracht in
unserem land befördern
man muss klarheit in seinen prinzipien
haben und die richtige urteilskraft bei
ihrer anwendung
manche fans verstehen die aufregung
nicht seit jahren singen wir sowas und
jetzt soll es verboten sein das ist
unsinn
für den nachmittag hatte die
französische liga chefin fans und
homosexuellen verbände zum
krisengespräch nach paris eingeladen
wir reden hier von einem problem das
kein rein französisches ist homophobie
gibt es auch in anderen ländern
vielleicht können wir davon lernen wie
man dort im fussball damit umgeht
deutsche fan beauftragte sagen
hierzulande würden fans homophobie nicht
einfach hinnehmen
in deutschland haben wir gott sei dank
die situation dass vor einigen fan
initiativen hier aktiv sein das heißt ja
eine ganz andere akzeptanz in den kurven
die anti diskriminierungs arbeiter sie
aus den kurven entstanden nach ihrem
krisentreffen gelobte die französische
liga am abend besserung
heute ist der tag mehr culpa zu sein
entschuldigung wir haben zu lange
hingenommen was nicht mehr hinnehmbar
ist wenn wir sehen wie sich die
gesellschaft weiterentwickelt hat die
liga wolle nun gegen homophobie in
stadien vorgehen gemeinsam mit schwulen
verbänden vereinen und fan gruppen die
versprachen dabei mitzumachen
kein serbe richter macht weiter zunächst
mit einer meldung aus der luftfahrt
konkret geht es um rein er lang hatte
sich der billigflieger dagegen gewehrt
nun haben seine piloten in deutschland
erstmals einen tarifvertrag der sieht
nicht nur höhere fixgehälter vor sondern
bringt den piloten auch höhere
nettoeinkommen den künftig können sie
ihre einkommenssteuer in deutschland
zahlen
bisher wurde die steuer mit höheren
sätzen in irland eingezogen die londoner
börse hat heute ein überraschendes
angebot bekommen die hongkonger börse
möchte sie gerne übernehmen
sollte der deal tatsächlich zustande
kommen würde der größte handelsplatz der
welt entstehen aber er steckt wohl auch
noch ein anderes kalkül dahinter valerie
haller an der frankfurter börse
ja das kalkül dass sich peking zugang
verschaffen will zu einem der
wichtigsten finanzplätze der welt es
gibt also nicht nur die sorge das nicht
es gibt also die sorge dass nicht
hongkong sondern china hinter dem
angebot eigentlich stecken könnte das
hat natürlich politische brisanz da
schaut nicht nur london sondern
vermutlich auch brüssel genau hin
die londoner börse reagiert
zurückhaltend man wolle das angebot
sorgfältig prüfen
die börse ist das aushängeschild der
londoner city gut 35 milliarden euro
bietet hongkong für sie fraglich ob die
britische regierung sich darauf einlässt
china hätte einfluss auf unternehmen und
banken
darum hat das britische
wirtschaftsministerium angekündigt genau
zu prüfen welche sicherheitsrelevanten
auswirkungen das auf großbritannien
haben könnte die frankfurter börse hat
sich an der londoner rivalen schon die
zähne ausgebissen
jahrelang suchte sie immer wieder den
schulterschluss mit der london stock
exchange scheiterte aber letztendlich an
den wettbewerbshütern börsen in aller
welt fällt es immer schwerer mit
traditionellen
aktienhandel geld zu verdienen deswegen
suchen viele ihre rettung infusionen
das ist sicher auch ein grund für
hongkongs vorstoß dankeschön valerie der
september gilt als schöner monat auf
mallorca doch seit gestern haben es
urlauber und bewohner nicht nur mit
solchen windhosen zu tun
auch hagel sturmböen und starker regen
suchen die ferieninsel heim
sie knickten bäume um rissen boote los
und überschwemmten etliche straßen und
häuser der geplante schulbeginn wurde
auf morgen verschoben und auch am
flughafen wurde der zeitplan
durcheinandergewirbelt
und wie immer mittwochs haben wir noch
die lottozahlen 38 17 28 38 42 superzahl
1 die angaben sind ohne gewähr
weitere gewinnt sein finden sie auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 7 wir sind für hässlichkeit hat kann
sich vom berliner alexanderplatz
geradezu berührt fühlen
wohin der blick auch fällt er bleibt an
nichts schönem hängen das ist in dieser
konsequenz schon wieder besonders zu den
vielen architektonischen und
städtebaulichen highlights am alex
gehört dass aus der statistik zu ddr
zeiten war es das zentrum der
planwirtschaft seit über zehn jahren
steht es leer
wer berlin-touristen beeindrucken will
fährt sie dahin eine riesige ruine in
zentraler lage
das kann nicht jeder hauptstadt bieten
doch damit soll es bald vorbei sein es
gibt nämlich ideen und konkrete pläne
und die klingen sogar richtig gut
matthias sa berichtet hier soll alles
anders werden verheizt zumindest der
schriftzug auf dem dach fast 50.000
quadratmeter leerstand in bester lage
das haus der statistik am alexanderplatz
jetzt soll es zum modellprojekt werden
künstler harry sachs war von anfang an
dabei wollte eine andere art der
stadtplanung ohne
immobilienspekulationen dafür mit viel
platz für bezahlbare wohnungen für
ateliers und kulturprojekte im herzen
berlins
wir wollen wirklich zentrale wichtige
nutzungen wieder dort ins zentrum
zurückbringen und all das was an die
ränder verdrängt wurde
wirklich wieder vor ort versammeln das
glauben wir ist total wichtig für die
stadt das ist derzeit nicht die für
unsere gesellschaft und das hat
modellcharakter für berlin aber man
sieht auch global betrachtet
jetzt ist das haus zum spielplatz für
kreative geworden der zugewachsene
innenhof mit einem dorf ofen in dem
jeder sein brot backen kann
stadtgärtner pflanzen bohnen und
kürbisse zwischen den ruinen ein alter
autoscooter wurde zur bühne etwa für
tango abende umfunktioniert im ersten
stock züchten sie hauseigene bienen und
darunter probt der chor der statistik
[Musik]
die
jetzt ist der entscheidende moment
eigene der schönste moment vom haus der
statistik wo alle möglichkeit räume
geöffnet werden man kann sich alles
vorstellen
begonnen hat alles vor vier jahren als
ein künstlerkollektiv einfach ein plakat
an die ruine hängte hier entstehen räume
für kunst kultur und soziales stimmte
natürlich nichts das haus sollte
abgerissen werden platz machen für
neubauten aber die guerilla aktion
zeigte wirkung die stadt berlin kaufte
das gebäude
seither planen senat künstler und
architekten zusammen ihr stadtquartier
der zukunft es kommt hier rein in das
haus es ist total spannend weil wir
sagen immer kunst kultur soziales und
und und also eine stadt in der stadt die
ganz viel kreativität ausstrahlen soll
gebaut ab 1968 von fdj brigaden war das
haus der statistik ein ort an dem das
sed-regime daten sammelte und
fünfjahrespläne erstellte einst ein
vorzeige bau der ost moderne wie
gegenüber das haus des reisens oder das
haus des jahres viele sachen wurden aber
auch einfach waren leer und
verwahrlosten und sind dann irgendwann
abgerissen worden einfach weil sie
irgendwie erstmal störten
also man kann es so sagen es gab kein
konzept ein konzept gibt es jetzt schon
mal wohnen verwaltung kunst und kreative
freiheit in einem quartier am alles
anders platz in der mitte berlins
das war's im heute-journal gleich nach
dem wetter geht es mit dem
auslandsjournal weiter heute unter
anderem mit einem bericht über den
unheimlich heimlichen strippenzieher
hinter boris johnson brachialer bei exit
strategie sein berater dominik cummings
spitzname der dunkle lord wir sehen uns
hoffentlich morgen abend wieder mich
aber nicht denn hier auf diesem platz
begrüßen christian sievers
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
wasser des mittelmeeres ist richtig warm
zurzeit es gibt 24 bis 28 grad und
sowohl wassertemperaturen die bewirken
dass sich tiefs über dem mittelmeer
jetzt besonders gerne lange halten wie
dieses hier mit dem zentralen mittelmeer
aber auch das über dem westlichen
mittelmeer das weiter richtung
nordafrika zieht gleichzeitig breitet
sich eine hochdruckbrücke von russland
bis zum atlantik aus und über
skandinavien ziehen einige tiefs und die
dämpfen dort die temperaturen liegen
deswegen morgen nur bei 10 bis 20 grad
und sie sehen auch die kälte hier
nordafrika da sehen sie diese kleine
grüne blase und während die wärme hier
nördlich vom schwarzen meer jetzt immer
mehr abgedrängt wird kommt zu uns
nochmal spätsommerlich wärme aus
südwesteuropa heute nacht sinken die
temperaturen bei uns auf 15 bis 8 grad
denn es ist meist stark bewölkt bis
bedeckt und es fällt zwischen der
ostseeküste und dem sauerland auch noch
etwas regen bei einem böigen wind aus
westlichen richtungen
der tag morgen beginnt erstmal recht
dann aber setzt sich die sonne durch und
ab und zu kann es auch mal leicht regnen
vor allen dingen so richtung sauerland
oder auch im harz am sonnigsten wird es
morgen am oberrhein da strahlt die sonne
und deswegen steigen dort die
temperaturen schon morgen auf 26 grad
sonst werden 19 bis 24 grad erreicht
freitag ändert sich wenig und ab
wochenende das schöne spätsommerwetter
für uns alle
schönen abend noch